[Music]
welcome back to chef's out of water I'm
Alexis and I'm a chef who's always up
for a challenge that's why I've taken to
the Internet to decide what I should
cook with today I don't know who I'm
cooking for and they don't know what I'm
gonna use so let's see what's in this
box
this feels like a personal attack you
know last time when I used a microwave
it didn't go exactly as planned per se
oh my god
I honestly like I this is a disaster I'm
really hoping to redeem myself this time
and make something that I'm actually
proud of do I at least get researched
this time better than research hi Alexis
and tasty I'm Gemma Stafford a
professional chef cookbook author and
the host of the online baking show
bigger bolder baking now although I'm
professionally trained chef I do know a
thing or two about cooking in the
microwave some of my most famous recipes
have been a pizza in a mug a three layer
cake in the microwave and even a whole
batch of brownies made in the microwave
okay these look amazing I didn't even
know that was possible
Alexis here are some of my microwave
tips to get you through this challenge
successfully tip number one err on the
side of caution when it comes to your
timing start out with around 2 to 3
minutes on the clock
then check in the microwave and if you
need more time after that 2 shorter
increments I think that's one of the
biggest takeaways from last time is I
was doing really long increments and
stuff was catching on fire tip number 2
microwave on full power personally I
don't use any of the settings on my
microwave if you follow tip number one
you'll be more in control of the time
and less likely to set the place on fire
I feel really comforted that Gemma
doesn't use different voltages it feels
kind of intimidating to me and if she
doesn't I don't need to do it either ok
tip number 3 Alexis
stay close to the microwave when it's on
I watched your previous challenge and
you went all the way around the kitchen
when you put something
there stay close by so you can keep an
eye on it and you're less likely to have
anything go wrong okay I think this is
just a good tip for being in the kitchen
I should know better
Alexis I wish you the very best of luck
and don't burn the place down
she seems to believe in me I have a
second shot I think I can do this
instead of a traditional three-course
meal I'm gonna do three different brunch
items three-course brunch one surprised
taste tester and one microwave let's see
if I can do this I'm going to start off
with a quiche how bad can it go I'm
gonna try to make a crust for the quiche
I know there's a lot of like crustless
quiche in a microwave but again I want
to try to elevate this I want to try to
make it a little more advanced last time
I did burn the crust of my lemon bars
might have caught on fire but I'm gonna
listen to Gemma's advice and go really
slowly this is gonna be a really
standard crust got my flour pinch of
salt its dirt all around easy it's
really important that the butter stays
cold again cold dairy equals a flaky
crust
once the butters all in then you can
start using your hands to start breaking
it apart I'm using ice water you could
also use apple cider vinegar some people
use vodka just helps make the dough a
bit more tender so I'm just gonna shape
these into two disks wrap them in
plastic wrap they should chill for about
an hour especially because it's so hot
in here I want the dough to be firm so
it can roll out to the fridge so I've
got one of my chilled dough disks whoo
she's tender Wow
see those pads of butter that means
super flaky and the butter yes I do I
love butter
how about you another very cool trick if
you want to transport your dough you can
just roll it like this oh my God look
how cool this is and then you can just
put it right back on and go like that
magic so my dough feels really soft
right now just because it's getting so
hot from the light so I'm actually going
to just chill it for maybe five minutes
while my crust chills I'm going to cook
off some bacon five minutes with a paper
towel but also Gemma said did not do
anything more than two minutes so I'm
going to do two minutes and then
increments after that look at me learn
[Music]
that was seven minutes
honestly it looks good there's still a
few parts that aren't super crispy but
it's gonna be baked again in the quiche
so I think it's fine it's pretty good so
much less rubbery than last time
so I've just got some eggs here gonna
beat the eggs with some milk heavy cream
add a pinch of salt cheese bacon if I
was making this quiche at home I would
be doing everything exactly the same up
until this point part breaking is when
you bake a crust by itself first put
parchment paper down and then put
something like beans
some people use pie weights you want to
make sure that the pie weights are
smooth it in an even layer otherwise
you're gonna get some burning underneath
I'm gonna start with two minutes goodbye
god I hope this works
I think we're filming on the hottest
week of summer it's certainly a heatwave
right now and there's no a/c in this
room you're welcome
I've been doing this for about 15
minutes
okay the edges are pretty pale but the
center is getting brown the edges of the
crust definitely need more time but I
think I just have to put the eggs in and
see what happens otherwise the bottom is
gonna be scorched
I mean this looks great really really
really want this torque I'm not gonna
walk away I'm gonna just sit right here
with this hob microwave and babysit my
quiche
let's take a look at this this is very
weird it smells great the quiche needs
more time the crust is still pretty pale
back and it goes okay
I'm just gonna try it I'm gonna open it
it's pretty weird but I just the crust
is like not cooked I'm gonna let it come
to room temperature I'm gonna try a
slice if it needs to be cooked tomorrow
I will reevaluate moving on I'm going to
make super fluffy banana chocolate chip
pancakes actually developed this recipe
for tasty 101 they're legitimately the
best pancakes I've ever had but I've
never made them in a microwave so we'll
see so I've got some flour a few
tablespoons of sugar pinch of salt
baking powder and baking soda I've got
my milk melted butter I also separated
the yolks and the whites for the eggs
helps them be really fluffy with pancake
batter you actually want to leave it on
the clumpy er side and actually see some
pockets of flour it's gonna help it make
it really fluffy then add the egg whites
you just want to stir until the egg
whites are just combined I'm gonna do
test without the banana and chocolate
chips
first because I don't know how long this
cooks and I don't want to be wasteful
I'm just spray down a microwave-safe
plate and then add some lumpy batter
the pancakes have spread all over the
plate so I think I need to use a smaller
plate or I need to use something that
can be like a like a mold a mold for the
pancake there's literally no one on the
planet who wants to eat this it's not
that bad
Wow okay okay so I got a few different
vessels I thought it could be fun to try
and I'm ramekin first and put a little
scoop batter in also gonna do two
minutes straight off huh
okay to me this looks kind of like a
little cake more so than a pancake let
me just see if this one with the lips
will help okay
doesn't look beautiful but that's okay
don't judge a book by its character
don't judge a book by its character
cover well yes the heat is getting to me
honestly I think it's as good as it's
gonna get I want to serve them with some
fruit some syrup on the side I think
there's a few of them it'll make them a
bit more appealing voila
they're not totally browned they're not
really fluffy but it's pretty cute I
think I'm ready to move on to my final
course so far things are going pretty
well I think my confidence is at a seven
solid seven for my final course I'm
going to try to make Eggs Benedict
traditionally Eggs Benedict is over
Canadian bacon on an English muffin
poached egg on top I don't really like
Canadian bacon so I'm gonna use
prosciutto sorry Canada I'm gonna cook
it just the same way I did the bacon
it's already cured it doesn't need to be
cooked I just thought it'd be nice to
get some like Chris penis two minutes
crispy prosciutto Wow that was the
easiest thing I've ever done so I've got
some eggs here I'm gonna pour some water
over it and add a little bit of acid 30
seconds two minutes a minute a minute
I'm gonna do a minute oh I mean it did
kind of pump in [ __ ] I need to clean
this up and I'm gonna try again
so that was a bust to say I'm gonna omit
the lemon juice this time and go in
30-second intervals that feels better
oh okay it's working it's working very
slowly look at this Oh poached egg this
is amazing this is amazing this is
amazing
okay here's the thing here's the thing
it's still cooked a little too far but I
think if I do like 15 seconds and then
another 15 seconds for the last egg
it'll be perfect
no lemon juice a little less time
poached eggs are happening this is not
perfect but look at that weird egg why
did that happen this is the problem
microwaves inconsistency I think I need
to get a few more eggs what in the hell
is happening I thought he just figured
it out
why is it doing this you know what I
think we need bigger bowls we I I need
bigger bowls maybe more water too and
you know what back to the lemon juice
taking it out kind of looks like an egg
ghost this is beautiful a little weird
but pretty good I'm gonna do one more
egg hopefully it works I've been told my
surprise guest is 15 minutes away so I'm
gonna finish this egg up move on to the
hollandaise and get plating so I've got
my egg yolks lemon juice salt pinch of
cayenne and then I'm gonna strain the
melted butter and give it a stir pop it
in the microwave and I think 30 seconds
one oh it's not the worst hollandaise
I've ever had it's fine
it's totally fine hollandaise on top
whoa damn she thick I'm just gonna add a
few chives I don't want to shock anyone
but a little flaky Cecil okay I think
we're ready for the taste test what a
weird day
it's me Gemma Stafford from bigger
bolder baking I'm here in the tasty
kitchen to see what Alexis has come up
with today I have a feeling Alexis went
pretty ambitious what she made in the
first video I'm sure she tried to talk
that and maybe she learned a thing or
two so I'm hoping it's going to be a
step above your video was amazing thank
you I mean it's more helpful than any
research I could have done I have to say
your first attempt was like really
ambitious like such ballsy but you know
you learn from your mistakes I'm hoping
that you improved on it for today hey
let's get started
so for brunch number one it's a bacon
and Gruyere quiche oh my gosh I love tea
did you do the pastry in the microwave
I did my gosh she's crispy what's
amazing
you actually have layers in your pastry
that's amazing thank you of course - is
Eggs Benedict
it's with crispy prosciutto instead of
Canadian bacon because I like its fancy
is this really good flavor and I have to
commend you the fact that your
hollandaise is pretty rockin and it
didn't split the hollandaise is a win ya
know that that's really awesome I think
you nailed us and the crispy prosciutto
okay so these third oh my gosh chocolate
chip banana pancakes that is awesome
they're not like regular pancakes
obviously but for a microwave I feel
pretty proud okay you tasted these I did
it is on the drier side it's on the
drier side yep your strawberries are
really good I worked very hard on this I
think there's some things that like copy
Beach I think that's like pancakes from
a griddle completely agree I have to say
you absolutely would have fooled me but
these other two I think you came to
compare it to the first video and to
here I think you're you're moving up in
the microwave but we're not gonna do the
pie case I think you did awesome and you
know what you did so good I have a
little present for you so this is a
bigger bolder baking bug specifically
for making mug meals it okay I could
have used this like eight hours ago you
guys done all of it in this mold see
it's a spork and it comes in the handle
see it you mix everything microwave
ETA's you're good to go
thank you this is for you so I'm just
gonna take this long ago I feel so good
I feel elated I feel so proud of myself
this was such a wild day there were
peaks there were valleys but ultimately
I think I redeemed myself with the
microwave what's next this is another
present okay what am I gonna do in the
blindfold this is a safety hazard to
cook blindfolded oh god I think I'm
ready
[Music]